歡迎回來趙華
我們今天的大來賓
也是大家非常熟悉的
以及艾倫有半路去認識
半路認識
半路認識的K線之神
朱家弘 朱老師 歡迎
主持人好 大家好
我們都已經很熟悉了
但今天我們要跟朱老師敬禮了
因為朱老師是標股上校
也是K線之神
敬禮 五萬點要起功了
要升將軍了
要升三軍總司令了
要請大家一起來供5萬點
那很多人都會抱怨
這一波根本就是賣飛了
或者是剛賣完就漲停板了
好 那要不要再買回來
這就是一個非常艱難的問題
如果我們能夠4萬看5萬
當然要買回來
對
我們本來就是看趨勢啦
趨勢如果還是往上有機會
那該買的時候
你還是要買回來
所以我們今天很體恤
我們的觀眾朋友
我們有歸納了很多
觀眾朋友在學技術型態的時候
一定會問的問號
不問題 大QA
朱老師今天看圖一個一個
來幫我們做解釋
好 第一個就是
我知道它不是多頭
我也知道它可能已經長多了
但我忍不住想買
因為我看到它利多很多
所有
這個也是我們做股票
經常會被誘惑
就是說被盤中誘惑
今天又漲又亮
或者有利多消息
那你就很想買
可是我們學技術分析
有一定的條件
然後才出手的
其實這也是人性
其實在做股票裡面
最困難的就是克服人性
因為每個人都怕不買來不及了
對不對
所以可能也知道說
還沒有收盤
就很想趕快先進去買
尤其是上漲的過程
想追
像這種狀況的話
你都已经知道你的问题了
你自己都知道吗
你说你条件不熟
但是你又忍不住
那就慢慢的去要求自己
这个位置还不到
这个在高档不要去追
就是经常提醒自己
那如果你真的想下单的话
我的建议啦
你就站起来离开一下
去喝口水
我以为你会叫我们说
那就用个铃骨啊
或怎么样的啊
不是你买铃骨跟买人骨
不是一样的
你買靈骨要賠也是賠啊
也是賠錢
所以基本上來說
就稍微的冷靜一下
給自己10秒鐘以後再說
就離開現場
其實有的時候
我們在看盤的時候
真的會忍不住
因為比如說
有的時候大盤早上開高
然後急車又殺 然後又拉
所以你看那個股價
也是漲漲跌跌
那早上一開高
你就很想買
那結果殺下來
你又說還好沒買
結果又拉上來
哎呀 刚才应该买
你看
前后不过几秒
你的心情就一样
那你就知道这个盘中
经常会让你忍不住
那我们就把手说一下
然后就稍微走开一下
我觉得离开比较好
三分钟 五分钟你再过来
可能你那个时候
就不会想买了
就稍微冷静一下
朱老师有曾经因为冲动
就先买了后面的成果
不理想或者是反而
不打不撞買到標誌
這一定會有的
剛開始的時候
大家 我講這人性
大家都認為強的時候
很想就要去買
可是你經過幾次
你買了結果不理想
你還是要賠錢
那你慢慢就認知說
為什麼可以忍住了
因為你已經在裡面賠過錢了
你就會忍住了
但是我還是不希望
你賠錢再忍住
就是自己去
其實我有講過
股票市場它就是一個道場
它就是在修煉的
最難的其實就是這部分
你明知道不對
但是你還是會去做
這個就是最難的
其實我們在社會上
在生活中也經常有這樣
你明知道闖紅燈不對
可是你走到這邊看沒有人
趕時間沒有人
你就很想趕快過
原本手癢变巧癢
所以这就是个人的一个
要去股市里面去修行
江朱老师我想要反问一下
我们知道技术这个条件已经成熟了
但涨停了 我买不到
那怎么办
这也是会碰到
完全相反的
我的想法就是
这不该我的就不是我的
修行好吗
因为股市里面也有缘分
真的很缘分
很多人做股票会觉得
我做哪些股票跟我特别有缘
我只要買它就很容易賺到
那有些股票買了就是賺不到
別人賺到我就賺不到
那我們就來看範例好不好
講了那麼久
景碩當然想買啊
宅版誰不想買
難得跌下來
對啊
今天就衝進去買吧 朱老師
對
我們來看一下
這股票也是一樣
其實我講的不是這個位置
是這個位置
什麼位置
因為這個位置是回後買上的
當天是不是盤中拉到很高
你可能就想說
就想說今天有放量
今天又大漲
我再不買就漲停板了
那我沒錯啊
可是你買了以後收盤
它就下來了
這是你盤中太衝動了
因為就像剛剛講的
因為你盤中還沒有確認
還有一兩個鐘頭要交易
那還有一個就是
快收盤了
它真的是戰勝五軍了
就是剛才那個問題
但是條件不成熟
為什麼條件不成熟
因為這個地方流歷很長的上限
它当天爆大量又流了很长的
那这代表什么
代表你前面这个黑黑压力过不去
那你又想说
哎呀我试试看好了
我先买一下
那结果你发现第二天就没有涨
然后这天就杀下来了
当然我还是讲
如果你稍微的
因为我们有时候在盆中会
思虑没有那么周到
有时候真的会就去买下去了
但是如果你真的买下去了
你还是有一个办法补救
就是守紀律
那你就趕快停損
不然的話明後天再跌
你就變大賠我們在股票場就有一個最大的原則就是不要大賠你只要不要大賠我保證你在股票市場你做的越久就賺的越多你一定會越賺越多
好 巴菲特說過啊
股票市場的第一條守則就是不要賠錢
對 不要賠錢
第二條也是
遵守第一條
但是景碩如果到月線沒有破
是不是可以買了呢
對
因為它現在是一個
它這個是回後上漲
對
那你现在下来
如果你破月线
这又是我们刚刚讲的
技术面不成熟
因为我们做多要在月线上
要站在月线上
那可能这也是大家容易
我跌破月线
可是今天大量红K
你又冲进去了
你又缺了一个条件
你还没有站上月线
但是你多练习几次啦
下次你就会知道
还是等它上月线
比较保险
因为宅办可能是很多人
很想上车
是的
但是不要盲目的追
所以等一下看看
景碩月線能不能守住
還有就是我也覺得
常常很討人厭的
可能今天上漲
就要回後買上漲
我有符合朱老師講的
結果第二天就大跌了
我跟你講很多觀眾會留言
朱老師說他多頭已經完成
朱老師說他上漲機率高
怎麼還可以跌
那我有講過
朱老師也有講過
技術分析
據說分析不是百分之百的
對不對
我們是講勝率 講概率
這個地方的回後上漲
剛才那個上影線就是概率不高
你要過高的概率不高
那可是我買紅K次女吧
明天還是跌
那各位就想說為什麼
那基本上你問什麼原因
應該是幕後的原因
就是消息面
或公司有沒有什麼
但是我一直強調就是說
大部分的散戶
應該都不是這個專業人士
对公司的很了解的
应该都是后知后觉
对 除非你是专业的
像这个专门研究产业的
那你又要做股票
又要赚钱
那你一定会碰到这种问题
我今天买明天就会跌
所以我才刚才有讲
技术分析还有一个最重要
你要配合起来
你才会赚钱
不是你学技术分析
就会赚钱
就是你的技术分析
要加上纪律
你就会赚钱
如果你不加纪律
那个技术分析
你是不会赚钱的
那因为你不守纪律
所以技术分析对你来说
就等于没有技术分析
因为你没有技术分析
你也是这样做
我只是给我一个理由
对 你只是找个理由
所以如果是第二天大跌
如果我把它简单一点
大家不要搞到那么复杂
要什么原因
要问了半天
应该我要怎么办
要追根究底
对不对
明明这个还说业绩很好
那它为什么会跌
可是很多人纠结这个事
但是做股票其实为什么会赔钱
就是因为你纠结的太多了
你在这个市场里面想的太多了
那我很单纯
它今天跌背后一定有原因
只是我们不知道
那怎么办呢
那我们就停损了
大跌就停损
不然我为什么要设个停损了
对不对
我每次买都涨
那就不用停损了
就是你买的时候
一定有机会会碰到大跌
那我就停损
好 那朱老师我们继续做这个问题
买了隔天下跌
然后呢停损
隔天又上涨
是怎样
老师要去拜拜
这也是我学技术分析那么多年
因为大家也知道
我三十几岁就做股票了
可是学技术分析是57岁
对 57岁
所以我32岁开始做股票
也做了二十几年
就是这个问题
我卖了明天又涨
到底要不要买
要不要再买回老婆
或者是昨天又被骗了
这个庭损你自己认为被骗了
可是技术分析学完了以后
我们就知道原来股票市场涨涨跌跌
背后是有一只手在操纵的
也许是主力
昨天大涨一大堆散户跟着
因为现在我的学生上万都在学技术分析
对不对
我想現在越看懂的人越多
那主力知不知道
主力當然也知道
主力我今天好不容易拉上來
怎麼搞的一大堆
有一萬個人放在那裡
我拉個五千張上來
怎麼裡面有一兩千張
都是跟上來的
那他可能第二天就要去做洗盤
那我們為什麼要停損
因為我們不是主力
我們不知道主力的想法
主力有可能不是洗盤
他可能真的
這個背後有什麼利空
他知道了
他干脆我不要做这一次
他整个就给你
就放弃了
那结果你没有停损
结果你这次就变大跌了
对不对
因为你没有停损大跌
所以我刚刚有讲
停损是保护我们的
万一这是真的跌的话
那我就避开一次大赔
所以我刚刚有讲
如果你会停损
你在股票上不会赔
你一定活着啦
你一定不会被抬出去
至少先做到不会赔钱
对
所以我们不要去预测
到底它是真的停损
还是假的停损
那我们就做
那做完了以后
结果它又涨了怎么办
那在技术面来说
这个又是另外一次机会
每个人在交易
都留了一个残忆
就是上一次赚大钱
所以这次应该还会赚大钱
每个人是不是有一个惯性
这次股票就像我们
讨论的那个记忆体
前面是不是
哇 涨翻了
那可是有一段
是不是变空头
所以你在空头里面
你还会再做
再做
因为想
哇这个财报很好啊
这个还在涨下啊
可是这一段
你就会大跌
对不对
就会越赔越多
没错嘛
所以我们不要去
我们不要去想
就是说
你一个股票买进去了
然后你把它卖掉了
这一次的生意就结束了
这等于在做生意嘛
生意给close掉了
对对对
我常常讲说
我们做股票就开杂货铺一样
你进了一个红海
现在红海
哇市价涨了
那你把它賣掉
所以你就賺錢了
你不可能進的商品
都抱在身上
都不賣
所以你漲了你就賣
可是如果這個商品有風險
你如果現在不趕快賣掉可能要賠更多那你就先把它賣掉那卖掉了第二天这个商品还是很值钱再进货重新再做一次生意是不是
对
你是另外一个开始
等一下你刚刚用紧说
现在用心心
心可以再做生意就对了
我们在这个过程中
机会来了我就买
然后我赚钱了我就卖
可是这边有没有发现
当你黑肩卖了
第二天就不跌了
所以这也是一样
你是不是觉得
早知道我就不卖了啦
不卖就凹单成功
尤其是你围头看
哎呀我不卖我就赚翻了
这都是你讲的啦
那如果你不卖
这边不卖
有没有跌了一两个礼拜
它就有跌啊
那如果碰到那个你就不讲了
我卖对了
是不是
你就两个结果嘛
那我们为什么说
技术分析你要做的周期
自己决定
你如果做短线
那你就这边卖
你如果做长线
那你到这边都还没有卖
所以技术分析就是
你先规划好
就没有所谓的后悔不后悔
因为我本来就要做短线嘛
所以我短线获利卖了
第二天
不跌了
你是不是要准备来了
再买嘛
因为你是做短线
就把昨天做的决定
先把它忘记
不是 因为这个已经结束了
结束了
你的账都进到你账户了
你还在想这个干什么
所以耗牢的人
都是因為你的想法是還會漲
所以你才抱著嘛
那結果它越來越跌
所以你這個就另外再做一次嘛
那同樣的今天是不是跌破五軍了
那你要不要賣
要吧 如果做短線要做嘛
你的紀律嘛 你已經賺錢了嘛
那明天漲是另外一次嘛
另外一個生意
所以每次結束你就把錢沒有忘掉
還有為什麼要忘掉
我的經驗啊 我以前做閃褲的時候
我这段赚了很多对不对
结果我做下面一段
跌了我就不卖 没关系
因为我上次有赚了
有没有这个心想
上次赚了50块
这个跌5块跌8块有什么关系
凸一点而已嘛
结果你上次的就凸光了
那我们做股票
你的财富是累积的
那你上次赚了你又吐又吐
你怎么会累积
很多人都会这样想
你为什么这不卖
没关系啦 我有赚到啦
你如果是這樣想
也就是說富人的想法
跟窮人的想法是不一樣的
富人怎麼會這樣想說沒關係
我再少賠 再多賠一點沒關係
不可能
所以你把這個思維改變了
你做股票
你就一段一段就去賺錢
不過有時候會卡關
如果是同一檔我剛停損完
他就大漲
我可能就會寧願去看別人
這個就比較難
這個就是你要練
而且尤其是在底部
底部阻力往往不会一次就攻
它往往就攻了就洗
攻了就洗
所以你看底部有时候长得很慢
对
可是到后面就飙起来了
结果你前面被它洗了
后面飙你就不做了
就这样子啊
前面被洗了后面飙就不做了
好有道理喔
因为被咬过了嘛
它被咬了嘛
对不对
这都是我的散户
我在散户之后经验
所以我去学技术分析
最后懂得技术分析的道理
它的道理就是说
你不要管市場裡面
本來你就沒辦法去預測的
所以也有一個理論
市場裡面根本是不可能預測的
那我們就不要預測
它漲我就做
它跌我就走
漲三天賺三天
漲五天賺五天
那我如果一直守了這個紀律
你就可以知道你自己的結果
對不對
這個連我都覺得很受用
因為我到現在還是
香主老师刚刚讲一句
洗的时候你就被洗掉了
喷的时候你就都没有了
这个我们常常有经验
对
好
那如果今天我们千挑万选
真的买一个股票
就买完下跌
是不是刚好更便宜了
我就再加码呀
这也是散户的想法
分批进场
对呀
因为散户
没错吧
各位我要知道
散户买一只股票
跟我们学技术分析是不一样的
我们学技术分析买这只股票
是因为这个图形
这个位置好
对啊
散户买这支股票
是因为听这个消息好
这家公司好
对
所以我今天买了
哎呀明天有低点
那我是不是可以再多买一点
当然了
比天天还便宜啊
对
所以这就是散户
很容易被套牢的原因
我一直讲
第二个
为什么散户不可以加码
并不是说不能加码
因为
那什么样才要加码
因为我们是散户
对
你看外资
跌也买
涨也买
对不对
他钱多
投信也是啊
一直买
他拿我的钱
我们散户你有那么多钱吗
没有嘛
所以散户就有一句
千万不要下跌加码
下跌加码不叫加码
这叫摊平
上涨加码才叫加码
很多人把这个都解释错了
往下不叫加码
虽然你股票变多了
其实你这个叫摊平
你的意思是在摊平
想成本降低一点
那我们散户我刚讲
你口袋不够深
那如果说第二天跌2% 5%你去买
那又跌2%你又买
那下次又杀个跌顶板
那你要不要再买
对不对
所以我们散户不要加码
因为加码你一样
你就被套牢了
因为你是跌
那你加码是不是已经在赔钱了
那如果已经在赔钱
你怎么还会加码呢
朱老师好挑战我左侧加码的意志力
因为我就是喜欢跌了加码的那个人
對 今天這支華通已經是變成
頭頭低了
它已經變頭頭低了
那換句話講
如果你在這裡買
那如果跌你去加
你這樣一直加一加
其實你的成本到現在還沒有回來
對 因為你下面那個
跌的數量你會越加越多
對不對
會越加越多嗎
會越加越怕吧
對
怎麼還在跌越加越怕
所以我們有一句話
這個越貪越貧
就不要貪
尤其我們閃戶
你沒有那麼多錢去貪
那第二個
你不要去想這個鏈頭因為你一想就想去加那你加了如果再跌呢好 我們會舉華通做例子是因為前一陣子大熱門的低迴衛星那回檔到季線
它上去的時候
其實很多人就反應說
太好了 我就警報不放
或者是我中間有攤平
現在要賺回來了
所以今天這跟黑K
其實是不妙的
這就是我們剛剛
一系列的問題
一系列的問題就是
你前面這個華通好
大家都說好吧
所以你一定會在這買
那买的你一定不卖
这就是我们讲的
没有技术分析跟有技术分析的区别
没有技术分析的人做股票
是以自我为中心
感觉
我的想法
以技术分析做股票的人是
用技术分析为中心
该卖了我就卖了
没有自己的主张
所以这两个是不一样的
所以大部分的散户
像我以前就是以自我为中心
对不对
我聽了消息好我就買了
那你講我也認同
好好我就買了
對不對
所以我希望大家在
不管怎麼樣
你要找到一個方法
這個方法在股票市場是有效的
然後你就以這個方法為中心
而不要以自我為中心
因為股票市場不是繞著你賺的
是繞著市場賺的
市場漲市場跌
並不是你想它漲它就漲
那我們如果把思維改變
我相信大家以後做股票會越做越好
那滑通跌停板你會撿嗎
不會
我每次都被你們兩個吐槽
沒有關係
因為趨勢
好 這個就是一般散戶朋友最難的了
現階段最難
你應該也會有這樣的困擾吧
當然有啊
台光店 聯發科 台達店
對 都一直漲不回檔
我到底能不能追
對 你看散戶矛盾
剛才DM就說
叫我賣 我為什麼要叫我賣
對不對
那現在呢 又
高檔他又想追了
這個因為再不追來不及了
就像三萬變四萬 四萬變五萬
對
那我們在節目上也經常講
他一定會回來的
只不過是在哪一天
而且第二個我們講
你不要鍾情於某一支股票
你應該手上要有
十檔 二十檔
這種鎖股
好 觀察的股票
你隨時都可以有機會
那你這支沒有機會
它一直長
你為什麼一定要跟它去
就它特別顯眼啊
它就一直長啊
所以你這支股票要理
這邊誰要理它
對
在這裡沒有人要理
可是你現在就想追
現在高攀不起
那就一樣
假如你追到今天
真的風險就很大
因為前兩天都買不到
我今天就問朱老師
打開能不能買
今天這個量超大
爆大量
聯發科打開能不能進入
當然不能啦
我們一直講
做技術派的人就不能買
好不容易才打開
對 他今天盤中殺得很快
殺到平盤
那平盤能不能買
對啊 其實剛好
如果我們學技術分析者
這個叫標股嘛
對啊
漲停 漲停 漲停
這叫標股
標股 漲停打開是要賣的
不是給你買
前面就應該要上車了
對
那你
我們標股的辦法
如果你真的做到一支
掌停板打开
跌破5%
你就要卖了
表示今天其实
已经大量的卖亚图了
所以今天反而是联发科的卖点
以技术形态来说
那如果你舍不得卖
你可能又会说
老师你看
我没卖又拉上来了
对啊
其实这叫变盘线
对
高档
这个拉上来叫变盘线
不是拉上来多方的
这个明天不可以开低
明天一开低
你就赶快跑
那更要跑
因为你今天没跑嘛
所以明天开低的话
你就赶快走
要赶快跑了
对 因为这个量太大
你一开低
这个量就出来了
它的卖压就出来了
是 有一点点
它的利器好像快放进的感觉
对 费经也涨很多天了
好 那接下来的话我们来看
这个应该是这一波
到4万点以上大家最常问的
卖飞了怎么办
其实这也是跟技术分析的
纪律有关
这支股票如果你在这买
结果今天没有涨你卖了
那你就賣飛了
對不對
盤中有時候會洗你
我講主力會洗
我可能會賣在那個最低點
想說沒救了
沒救 隔天就噴噴噴噴
對 那我們就講嘛
你就沿著五軍吧
不管他今天紅的黑的上影線下影線
你沒有跌破五軍就不賣
那你就不怕被主力
他整一整整來整去的
因為有時候他是盤中洗
那第二天又拉就漲停
所以我們就講暗紀律
那這個就是也一樣
標股是不是按照紀律
對不對 你就賣了
賣了 怎麼又漲
你是不是很後悔
不用啊 你這邊再買
你現在又賺一段
其實你是賣在這邊
你買在這邊
你還多賺
比你抱起來還賺得多
因為你賣的比較高
買的比較低
所以你還多賺
我很可能就是賣在那天
有那個下影線說
不行了啦 就賠了啦
然後把它賣掉
然後這邊就噴漲停
這個賣是剛才我講的
標股的賣法
因為你已經獲利
一個漲停 兩個漲停 三個 四個
所以你高檔有這種變盤黑黑
你就趕快賣
這是技術面的一個操作技巧
還有賣飛
我覺得是心態上的調整
對啊
如果賣了之後
沒有勇氣把它買回來
那就算了
去看下一檔
不過如果你在行進高檔賣飛
你就不要買回來
因為你賣飛還是賺錢
可是你一買回來
搞不好
你就陪回去
就回到第一個問題
對
那個不一樣
那個是因為
你賣了它後面還有一小段
那你就算了那一段
那你又去追
哇糟糕了
結果你還又陪回去了
所以我們常常有時候跟朋友開玩笑說
它不會漲了
因為我今天買了
對
所以標股我今天買了
明天可能就不會漲了
有這麼一個魔咒在
所以今天朱老師
把這個散戶朋友們
在這一段時間的疑問
都告訴大家了
也很謝謝朱老師教導我們
而且我們會發現一件事
雖然朱老師的學生已經上萬個了
可是問題是永遠一樣的
跟當初可能只有十個學生是一樣的
這個...
這個怎麼講
交給你